so listen there's this misconception
that money can cure poverty or hunger
but that is the furthest thing from the
truth everybody thinks if you give this
person 450 000
they will never be poor again if you pay
people back money if you go out there
and help everybody get a million dollars
they will live a better life if you give
them ubi income they're going to live a
better life that is not true and here's
why recently
the the executive director of the un
world food program tweeted out saying
two percent of elon musk's net worth
which is around 6 billion because he was
worth 300 billion at the time can help
solve world hunger so everybody's like
oh my gosh he's so rich why doesn't he
take six per two percent of his money
and six billion dollars and make that
happen well from that moment some
interesting things happened because elon
musk responded and he said the following
thing he said look if you can prove to
me okay
that six billion dollars will solve
world hunger i will sell tesla stock
right now and do it but it must be open
source accounting so the public sees
precisely how the money is being spent
then while this whole conversation is
taking place another person gets
involved a man named dr eli david says
two percent of elon musk is six billion
dollars in 2020 u.n world food program
which is wfp raised 8.4 billion dollars
how come it didn't solve world hunger so
eventually this executive director from
u.n responds and says well i wasn't
really talking about world hunger we
were really talking about geopolitics so
now they're spinning and changing again
because they know if you give six
billion dollars open source accounting
there's no way you can do it six million
dollars it's always these methodical
ideas that oh my gosh if we give money
to poor
going to get fine here's the problem i
got with politicians and people who are
in leadership positions why are you
trying to solve problems from the
outside like you know when somebody is
out of shape and you need to lose 50
pounds there's two options you got you
can go get your stomach stapled for ten
thousand dollars so your your stomach
gets smaller and you don't wanna eat
that much right but you still are not
gonna exercise you're still not healthy
you still didn't solve the problem you
may lose 50 pounds you're still not
healthier because you're not exercising
the right way to get in shape is to
actually have to do the work i was at
the gym this morning for an hour i'm
training with my guy i'm not gonna lie
to you for an hour in my mind you know
how you play games and your mind plays
tricks on you for one hour i've hit this
guy in the face i've thrown him against
the mirror i've slapped him across the
face i've thrown my water bottle at him
i'm so angry at this guy
because for an hour he's kicking my ass
i'm sweating i'm almost in tears like a
little baby but at the end of it i get
in the car and i'm i can't breathe like
literally i can't breathe i'm drinking
all this other stuff
30 minutes later i'm like i had such a
great workout this morning you think i
felt like working out with this guy hell
no so solution let's just pay this guy a
little bit of money it's going to solve
it no it's not you have to work
internally so politicians leaders people
at the top i'm always confused when is
the last time you heard a senator a
congressman a mayor a president talk
about teaching people the basics about
how money works when tell me whose
campaign was ever about the next four
years we gonna make americans be better
savers by teaching them about how money
works by teaching about making better
investments by recreating your identity
by getting you to read the right books
internal this money game is not hard by
the way you're talking to a guy here who
went from being a kid of a father who
was a cashier at a 99 cent store in
englewood and mother who was on welfare
that ran out of money and went back to
iran and i joined the army because it
was my only way out
we had no clue money worked my parents
never owned the stock ever we've never
owned a 401k we've never owned the life
insurance policy when i told my dad i
sold life insurance when i told my mom i
saw life insurance you know what their
response was here's what the response
was i said i sell life and says what is
that i said so you pay a hundred dollars
and god for but if you die your family
gets three hundred thousand dollars he
says you believe that
he says you know that's con i said no
that's life insurance so that you think
someone's going to give your family 500
000 or 300 thousand dollars and you only
pay 100 and i say yeah because most
people live longer so it's a
mathematical formula you're crazy my
parents knew nothing about insurance
annuities 401k stocks months i knew
nothing about the stuff i've never lived
in houses it was an apartment complex
but i learned early on
if i work from here on how money works
with my identity then money will show up
so no money is not going to cure
poverty no money is not going to cure
world hunger different way of thinking
supported by people that are willing to
contribute their time and resources can
but if you just give money without
recreating someone's mindset without
recreating the way somebody thinks that
poverty is not going away they're going
to stay poor and they're just going to
rely more and more and more on you and
the more free money you give them matter
of fact it gets even worse over time the
more free money you give to people so
you know if you're listening to this
and this kind of got you thinking maybe
ask the local people that you work with
in politics ask your local congressman
your local mayor your local senator ask
your governor ask the president when's
the last time we talk to people about
how money works why not
why don't we have somebody campaign
around educating that community about
how money works maybe i'm crazy but i
don't think i am if you agree with me
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and share the hell out of this
video so we can get people asking the
right questions from our politicians and
if you enjoyed this video and uh i did a
video years ago talking about how to
recreate your set how to recreate your
mindset i got two videos i want you to
watch one of them is 10 ways how to
recreate your mindset and the other one
is 20 rules of money if you've never
watched 20 rules of money go watch the
video 20 rules of money and get a better
idea about how money works especially
how i think about money having said that
have a wonderful week everybody take
care bye
[Music]